how close you're going to be to the
actual cartoon because people wondering
what you're going to look like and
people know what the cartoon psylocke
looks like I think we have that here and
we don't know how close you're going to
be is it gonna be the same but it'll be
the same costume yeah except for this
part I come in I come into the deficit
with that part but the costume is
exactly like that just a lot less here
and here right I'm sorry
there's a lot of there's a lot of
lubrication involved in getting you into
the god it's true James and thank you
for knowing that someone needs to help
get lucky why yeah yeah they Lube me
he's the truth they lose me down and I
step into this latex we did a whole
latex fitting yes okay Andy you weren't
paying attention earlier I just blacked
out they lubricate the costume and then
you step in and they lubricate means
there's two well what what do they use
like butter margarine butter or
margarine
what are you tired oh no when were you
born it was right you know well you know
when you're in a pinch you use what you
got
yeah they based me first and then they
see me and then two women Lube me up and
then um then we I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah two women yeah Lou all right we got
it yeah
the first day I put on the latex suit
and I was out there I'm just really
excited to be with these guys and I've
met Michael and James and everybody and
I was just so excited and and then I
went to slicksters like okay I want to
do a really good job and I just popped
the crotch of the latex is broke
[Applause]
I guess bribes poppin crops poppin can
be a superpower